et bonsoir galia ackerman
vous êtes chef du bureau russie de la
revue politique internationale
rédactrice en chef également du desk
russie première question avec vous
volodymyr zelensky on l'a entendu un
s'est indignée la position de l'otan de
ne pas vouloir mettre en place donc
cette zone d'exclusion aérienne message
d'espoir également ukrainien autre côté
il reste dans sa posture qui là qu'il a
endossé le costume qu'il a endossé celui
de chef de guerre des ukrainiens
et je pense que même à 6 est un acteur à
l'origine qui a fait sa carrière en tant
qu'acteur maintenant c'est pas
simplement il a endossé le costume est
entièrement fusionnelle avec ce rôle et
les gens dans ces moments critiques ils
sont si ce faux ou si c'est pas faux et
on a l'impression en l'écoutant surtout
moi je peux l'aider en douce et antonio
je comprends parfaitement qu'il dit vrai
que c'est qu'ils disent qu'ils sont et
c'est très très important c'est pour ça
votre correspondant
parler de sa popularité vous savez il a
refusé d'être extrait il a dit qu'il n'a
pas besoin de taxi mais mesdames donc
[Musique]
d'inr
égalé ackermann est ce que d'une
certaine manière volodymyr zelensky
n'est peut-être plus largement l'ukraine
et la résist les forces ukrainiennes ont
gagné cette bataille de la communication
dans cette galère selon vous
la bataille a été gagnée mais la guerre
ne sais pas comment ça peut se terminer
même maintenant le général français je
verrai de potes a reconnu qu'il y avait
une menace réelle d'une frappe nucléaire
on sait pas trop où mais poutine a
clairement menacé de sceptre et comme
lui c'est une fuite en avant il pensait
qu'il allait conquérir le crème dans sa
réalité parallèle il pensait qu'on
allait l'accueillir en ukraine comme
libérateur des mythiques nazis
et mais rien de tel ne s'est produit la
résistance c'est très acharné et donc
donc à ce dixième jour la guerre elle
n'est pas à gagner mais pour l'instant
en tout cas elle n'est pas perdue le
parisien nous avons également vous venez
de l'évoquer justement de vladimir
poutine qui lui aussi s'est exprimé peu
après
volodymyr zelensky il a donc dit que
ceux les pays qui souhaiteraient mettre
en place cette zone d'exclusion aérienne
serait considéré comme co belligérants
il reste donc dans sa posture le
président russe a rhétorique de menaces
il reste dans la même posture que
et qui a deux semaines quand il a
prononcé son discours je crois que
c'était le 21 janvier au soir
c'est à dire il est totalement dans son
délire nationaliste impérialistes on
peut dire parce que ne reconnaît pas le
crème comme abris à parler ce prénom
comme un peuple à part et donc ils se
croient en droit de conquérir le cren
tout comme il ya tant d'années et l'a
conquis latine il y avait deux guerres
tchétchènes la deuxième c'était le 10
mai routine on sait d'ailleurs comment
les russes ont transformé la ville de
grozny en une sorte de dress de la ville
totalement ruiné en ruines donc
maintenant il considère qu'il a aussi le
droit parce que historiquement
le kremlin
a day a été
de centaines d'années faisait partie de
l'empiré russe donc ils se considèrent
d'agir un coup droit d'agir comme comme
si c'était son territoire à lui et comme
s'il essayait de mater à un
pays indépendantiste si l'on peut dire
dernier mot avec vous gallia galia
ackerman est ce que cette position de
poutine on a vu des réactions
d'opposition à ces guerres aussi en
russie est ce que pour la dîmière
poutine peut être fragilisé est ce que
peut-être on pourrait éventuellement
assister à une révolution de palais
comme on dit en russie peut-être
personnellement je pense que c'est la
seule solution
parce que en termes de liberté c'est la
nuit noire qui est déjà descendu en
russie on affirmé même les médias qu'on
n'a pas touché par des dizaines d'années
comme l'écho de moscou comme la chaîne
de télévision d'autres maintenant il n'y
a plus de facebook en russie il n'y a
pratiquement plus de twitter donc toutes
les informations que les médias russes
donnent ce sont des informations tout
simplement fausse et donc les gens ne
comprennent même pas et ne peuvent pas
comprendre ce qui se produit eux ils ne
voient pas des images de ces mines
détruites c'est toujours des mensonges
sur les frappes chirurgicales
uniquement sur des infrastructures
militaires et est donc entre les
répétitions extrêmement sévère et
ce mensonge donc l'impossibilité d'avoir
accès à des informations vraies sur ce
qui passe se passe je pense que la
révolution tout court ne peut pas avoir
nommé en revanche comme tout il va droit
dans le mur
il ya peut-être peut-être un espoir on
peut dire d'une révolution de palais un
coup d'état soit possible c'est
d'ailleurs ça c'est déjà plusieurs fois
produits et dans l'histoire soviétique
et même une fois une tentative dans
l'histoire post soviétique sous eltsine
c'est à dire tant qu'il n'y a pas de
vraie démocratie
en fait on peut se débarrasser d'un
tyran
uniquement pas une révolution de palais
merci beaucoup galia ackerman pour tous
cette équipe cet éclairage et ces
précisions je rappelle que vous êtes
chef du bureau russie de la revue
politique internationale